hello I'm Nicole check for skel JD MBA
class of 1995 as president of the GSB
alumni association in Beijing is my
honor to share with you some of the
stories from the many faces of the GSB
in China please join me as they share
with us their learning from Silicon
Valley and Stanford and how coupled with
their passion they are here to shape the
future of China and beyond
I'm Victor ku graduate from Stanford GSB
in 1994 and I'm currently the founder
and CEO of Youku Tudou Inc yoku in
Chinese means what's best in what school
the idea is when you are looking at
videos basically there's very
time-consuming it's very attention
grabbing and so you want to have a
platform that actually can help you find
the best and the coldest videos we
become a platform where people can
actualize their dreams whether they're
good is saying or whether they good at
directing or whether they have a special
talent
Anabelle own GSP 2005 before going to us
I worked in China hosted on TV network
right now I'm representing the biggest
the Media Group in Europe I'm doing
bunch of investments backing
enterpreneurs and running operation here
my name is dawn Lu I'm a year 2004 GSB
grad and I'm the founder and CEO of
Lemieux Lemieux is a lingerie brand that
try to combine the fashion side of
lingerie and the function together which
is good to look at as a lingerie and
also when you wear it it make you look
more beautiful and sexy sexy is not a
just a physical level it's also
spiritual
my name is why Shu I'm from class
l7 209 GSB and my company is simple that
I am it's a mobile application we enable
the users to use their real-time photo
stream to share their lifestyle we
choose photo as the most important media
for people's communication because
followers first very simple our product
is looking at the global market but it
started from China so 75% of the users
are from China 25% from global market
my name is Ahn I went to Stanford a year
2007 graduating year to some line later
I started my own company in Jimmy token
one largest e-commerce company for
cosmetics skincare in China we are not a
company which sells cosmetics and
skincare products we are complete to
help chase ladies to become more
confident become more beautiful to came
up my name is Elaine
I'm Stanford GSB 2010 currently working
for the strategy department of I do I do
with the largest search engine company
in China it has over 80 percent of the
market share over 400 millions people
are using it every day so that is that
in in its own sense it controls what
people can see and what cannot in a
country where there's still censorship I
do is like the the Gateway to the whole
online world
hi this is Alan Alan do I have graduated
from Stanford for almost 11 years and
luckily I'm working in one of the better
company in China is this in Jenin is
basically the largest real real name
social network in in China and it has
about 200 million registered users
that's basically almost 20 percent of
the whole population in China and it has
monthly active users about 50 minutes
I'm Chris Reynolds GSB 2004 I am prayin
GSB class of 2003 we're the founders and
general partners of trying to find art
management the institutions in China
aren't fully formed there they're not
static there they're also going through
change and that means that individuals
can affect the direction of development
of those institutions in a way that they
wouldn't be able to in more established
economies more established systems I'm
Anna Fang I graduated the GSB in 2010
last year I joined Jen fund as a general
manager things that are disruptive in
the technology space in the education
space are particularly interesting for
me at Jen fine you know I'm the general
manager and I'm 30 years old and I don't
think I would have this opportunity in
America to be you know running a leading
angel fund my name is Gabriel Lee and I
graduated from the Stanford GSB in 1995
and have been in venture capital and
private equity investing in China for
the last 15 years China has
traditionally been a state plan economy
so all of the different sectors were set
up in a way that is very different from
how a capitalistic economy has been set
up so the business models in China are
just emerging in comparison to what's
happening in the u.s. rule of law is not
terribly strong in China I don't think
it's controversial to say that so as a
result very national you have all of you
have a generation of people we're it's
basically chasing after material
material gains it's like the Wild West
over here and so you have to adapt what
has been successful in the u.s. to China
with the knowledge of what's happening
here and what are the regulatory issues
that are different here China as you
probably know is still kind of in the
developing stage the communication old
days among ordinary people was not that
efficient traditional media in China is
relatively restricted and really instead
is really the direct channel where the
average
Chinese internet and citizen which is
now over over five or eight million
people can get access to information and
entertainment around the wall this is a
place that I can relive my dream to be
not only a designer and creating that
brand but also create something that's
revolutionary that's changing the retail
apparel fashion retail industry in China
the Chinese young entrepreneurs just
simply doing better and me out how this
is my hometown and I'm class 98 I see
myself as an agent of change in the
senior executive business in China we're
in a very dynamic market and change is
the constant theme here yoku is an agent
of change because being the leader
internet television we're really on the
forefront of the convergence of mobile
PC as well as the television screen in
terms of delivery of video what were you
doing in the rapidly changing
environment of China is in some ways
changing the lives of the Chinese people
and Internet being really a window to
the world is helping change how the
average Chinese think and work and play
it basically helped people in China to
connect in a better way to each other I
think for now which changed the whole
industry
before we start this most people would
buy cosmetic skincare in offline shops
because they don't trust a nice online
channels we are the first one who gave
lots of trust from customers and for now
we are not just one in the whole sector
we came in firstly in China to have a
really open like relaxed policy so that
is first time in China in your lingerie
history I think that a laundry can be
returned we're thinking why why not if
you like it returned we give you
something you like a thief Anala ham was
at 20 million customers so we changed
lives of 10 million customers
China is the Center for dynamism in the
world and so 400 100 years it's been
China learning from the rest of the
world well who doesn't believe that over
the next hundred years it isn't going to
be the rest of the world learning a
little bit or learning something from
China it's no longer just a copycat live
for me especially in digital and the
media especially mobile space many of
the cutting-edge technologies and also
more importantly monetization business
models are coming from China in the past
developing countries learn a lot from
developed countries in terms of portals
and business models but we're starting
to see is that because of much more
fluid environment within developing
countries the product models that we can
create here as well as the business
models are also lessons where developed
countries can learn from - my name is
Eugene Lee I was class of 1994 at the
GSB I actually worked with a Stanford
classmate it's his family's business and
we also work with several other Stanford
colleagues our company would not exist
if it weren't for Stanford it's Stanford
is the mother of our company towards
people on the ground they are either
very successful energetic entrepreneurs
or their investors naturally you are in
the community if you want to be in the
trend so I think it's the really the
people actually I get to know via GSB
networks and also the classmates
actually who are really now funding
multi-billion dollar businesses give me
a lot of inspirations and open the door
for me to really start my investments or
my job in general here
I spent my two years in Stanford to look
for my co-founders Stanford played a
huge role in my company is a fundamental
motivation for me to actually dare to do
something like this yeah I started the
company at age of 36
I wasn't young but when I was - Stanford
certainly being around a lot of
entrepreneurs once brings the idea of
wanting to start a company my first
angel investor is a Geo steel on there
my classmate you know I just felt you
know I
I have no fear you know because I've
seen so many classmates of mine they've
done so many amazing things in different
countries different areas so why can i I
think what Stanford does incredibly well
is it teaches you how to find out what
is meaningful to you in a way that's
different than say it's the monetary
reward or the social status in position
what is truly important to you inside
and then how to take what is important
to you and actually turn it into a
career a life path for you and where
that life half is not like some
touchy-feely thing or some new-age
religious thing or a spiritual thing but
it really is your career it's how you're
spending your time making a way in life
and in society and actually creating
value for society
hello I'm so far but right now I'm
leaving in a working and busy and most
of times also I go to the outside of
China because when you run on the US I
think it's the innovation it's very
important to for the human being
so Stanford's one of icon in a word for
the innovation in China sometimes we
believe to live is to suffer it's some
Buddhist reaction so if you enjoy it's
almost a thing because you're not
supposed to you're supposed to really
endure great hardship in order to
achieve great greatness and Gretna's
Stanford has a more human approach if
you ever want to be a great individual
you better stay color tool great people
if you way ever want to make great
contributions to make great things
happen you better stay in a great place
and that's what Stanford can offer to
you they I went to Stanford because of
the culture their focus on their
people's true value and the atmosphere
in the heart of Silicon Valley as
someone working in real estate I know
the importance of finding the right
ocation Stanford Business School offers
a very close-knit culture in a beautiful
campus setting in the context of a
thriving entrepreneurial ecosystem I was
just a computer engineering graduate
fresh at that time mileage is not enough
for me to become a great CEO to manage a
billion or SAS company that's the reason
why I decided to go to Stanford for my B
school I chose to go to Stanford because
a lot because of the whole idea of
change and for me you know at the end of
the day I want to make an impact on the
world and and I want to I want to leave
something behind the thing that I
learned at Stanford is that you know
failures accepted in China actually
there's a lot of stigma sometimes with
failure a lot of people don't like to go
ahead and MIT failure and actually
that's a very important lesson because
sometimes people don't want to take the
risks and if you don't take risks you
may never fail but you may never achieve
anything or change anything
a lot of other schools really have a
very much individualistic approach to
learning and and competition and so
forth I think Stanford's created a
cooperative environment that is very
different from a cultural perspective
from other business schools change lives
my name is Amy gu and then I'm Jess the
class of 2009 Ratna ujm of eronel China
if you want to change world you have to
you know start from change you know the
lives which pretty much means in a
change from yourself first
my name is her slain and
the general panic here in DC in China
and in the past six years I have been
making investments here so changing the
world is not about changing big way or
small way is really just changing the
the the environment around you that you
can actually do make a difference and
turn it into something that you think is
better for the future and I think that
that's really what life is all about
without that I don't know you can't be
go and and I think everyone needs to to
have a philosophy and I think that
that's the philosophy that I hold and I
think that's a pretty good philosophy to
go by this Stanford model actually makes
me feel relieved because changing the
world doesn't mean you have to be
president of of a big country but you
can do small things little by little and
change the world around you you can
start changing yourself and making
things easier and better for the people
around you if you really think about the
training the education and the people
around you during the time you're at
Stanford really goes back to being an
agent of change being in a changing
environment being able to adapt to it
and being able to excel in it we want to
change the world the first thing is to
find your energies just to change your
own life change your attitude your way
to communicate with the world then we
can do that change lives inspire people
let people working for you happy know
what they're doing then you have this
strong organization then you can go
wherever you want to go when we're
changed and worth our thoughts our
behavior changed our products and our
services changed and we're creating
better probably actually different more
fun and bulk products and services and
actually that influence now you know we
have we changed in a way more than 1
million people in China coming out maybe
in a some naive way discussing issue
beyond typical life but change in the
war is indeed why we're here today it's
our mission to bring chant you to this
whole world and to bring the positive
impact to to the world to me that really
means contributing to society
and being being an active person in
shaping the world we do not aspire to
change the world but in our little world
here in China
we have made we have invested in these
companies which have made changes to the
consumer behavior of consumers in China
what it really means is make a
difference make an impact
I thank Stanford for giving me the
courage to dream and to pursue my dreams
and to give me both the hard and soft
skills to do that so I haven't got my
co-founders from Stanford I got my
knowledge from Stanford and Stanford
really helped us to build this country
to a big one just in two years without
the life in Stanford I maybe I would
never even started this company I think
the greatest things that ever did for me
is indeed it opened my mind it provided
me the freedom of thinking
I think Stanford for all the experience
that has exposed me to as well as the
people that I've met through the
experience that's something I carry with
me since I graduated all through my
career in my life
I want to thank Stanford for you know
bringing so many brilliant people so
many brilliant honest unique people into
my life in Stanford I feel I'm more
capable of doing new things learning new
things and then accepting new challenges
and then adapting to the new changes
that it's something I think I will
then in other places I got a lifelong
business partner out of the out of out
of two years that I spent at Stanford
who knows even you go to Stanford who
you're going to meet and and how that's
gonna change the direction of your life
I think I'm I'm wiser braver and more
curious
thanks to Stanford thank you Stanford
for gave me a great opportunity given me
the most one for two years in my
lifetime and number two thank you for
making me to get or to offer me the
chance to meet up so many great people
and a number of them one of the best
friends I have right now
I started it you a so in environment to
manage all different part of your life
friendship relationship work and dream
and passion and helps you to shape
yourself from all these chaotic elements
of your life their talents are diverse
their passions are broad ranging but the
one thing that is consistent is that
they are all here to change lives change
organizations and change the world
I'm a living example alive this change
my Stanford what's important is the
delicate balance of work-life and
Stanford has a way to show you how to do
it
what's therefore make me more confident
more passionate and more disruptive
don't be boring
Stanford changed me in terms of how I
think about creativity and risk-taking
for me a stanford business school
environment furthered my drive to create
to collaborate and to try to make a
difference in changing the world
wait GSB Keith we had the stuff and the
company the things we are doing we also
have a self and that is a way how we can
go further the others
you